[Music]
in crazy cult news submitted by the JK
ladies are the best female South Korean
cult leader is arrested for stranding
400 followers in Fiji Oh Haitians be
getting lost strand them but it was like
they just went off on their own
this is like the tie thing but with 400
people yeah like the tie with the soccer
players slightly remember in the case
you're such a millennial that just
happened and I just like whatever [ __ ]
it no cuz I thought it was like a tie
thing where a whole bunch of people
follow a leader to talk people follow a
leader and they and then now there's 400
people following a lady and they all if
steding connected they don't get waves
out there they can't just use ways to
find their way back
hey wait where they go to Fiji because
she predicted it was a discount over
there they're gonna say oh man she just
buying time yeah so this South Korean
cult leader her name is shin up Joo oh I
wanted it to be shindig there she looked
like every Korean lady in my church yeah
that's funny I drew my nose
that is the prototype for Korean church
lady right there yeah once there like I
don't give a [ __ ] about dick anymore
they get a perm and they always have
that blazer like everything about her
looks like 70 except for her face and
her skin yeah that's it it's a surgery
face so she was arrested along with
three other leaders from the grace Road
Church they had 400 of their followers
go to Fiji starting from 2014 as soon as
her followers would land there she would
take away their passport and she would
force them to carry out these ritual
beatings on each other she claimed that
these beatings would avoid them from
being punished by God there was this one
father that was made to hit his
more than a hundred times according to
these people that escape because there
were five fuel that escapes my mom would
love something like this so there's four
hundred people that were trapped there
that's living in a community yeah it's
just a call to that's the regular Sunday
Korean like Sunday Korean dinner to me I
don't know that sounds like North Korea
on a Sunday right yeah
my mom's always looking for a call to
join she enjoys so many calls cos Tony
wanted a comedy where she's the kind of
cult member that the cults go Oh father
not her again another father was beaten
so badly that he was left with permanent
brain damage I could picture your mom
like doing some crazier [ __ ] that make
the cult people go hole [ __ ] like if
they tell her to beat everybody she's
like no no no no it she gets like a
baseball bat with [ __ ] like spikes
it's because this one were you gonna do
yeah Kali is just so weird like just to
foul somebody be like I know how the
world works but I was born in like 1980
it's just like we were like how do you
know while the world works you just got
here that's true just a [ __ ] person
like yeah I got to meet the people like
how broken were they that they met this
one person and they said i'ma listen to
everything that you say yeah well their
followers supposedly like look at you
and David Goggins dude well I didn't
listen to everything he said I took
literally a half a percent of what he's
a but I'm just saying take that and then
I'll magnify it by someone who's Falken
loss leaders are supposed to have real a
lot of charisma a lot of charm like you
know we only hear the negative parts of
it but when they're working their game
it's like a player oh yeah they know how
to work their magic on people you know I
want to meet one of these because we're
monogamous we're probably like you're
[ __ ] stupid but then there's people
out there that get no attention and here
comes this person that's telling them
that they're special and all this stuff
and it's like this protects how hulls
get tart
you know Holly me of Korean people who
feed you with a bunch of perms exactly
and you know how they like to keep their
skin all light as possible so it's hot
as [ __ ] over there so they're probably
looking awayand these days oh yeah she
looks like an Asian version of the mom
from king of the hill right no it's a
Peggy Peggy Hill version of that is
there like a rescue mission or like
what's going on you know I got to find
out more info about this story but
that's like what I've told you it's the
only thing that they're reporting but
she's not in Fiji no oh so she got
arrested in South Korea she probably
just vacations to Fiji yeah she got
arrested at the airport I bet you what
they do is they get you to turn over all
your assets and everything that you own
and then you end up being a free laborer
out in Fiji I never understand why these
cult leaders put a date on anything
because eventually that dates gonna come
yeah and no shits gonna happen you know
watch you keep it very vague yeah yeah
just the rapture is coming soon it's
gonna happen soon yeah the moon turn
there you go just give like something
really weird like and you have to wait
for it every night yeah not tonight
green I don't know it's a little like
tinge you said soon like 30 years ago
we're talking in the greater scale soon
within like millions of years how the
world was that's pretty soon a hundred
could be soon you just wanna be loved I
just say wanna join in so sad do you see
these Scientologists in LA they're like
they're very each their own but there's
nothing distinguished about them they
all look alike it's all what do they say
about gangs - right like white little
kids joined gangs Yeah right where I
trained it there's a Scientology
building in South Pasadena right oh the
one with all the books on the front I
was a little bit offended because there
was one little [ __ ] Scientology nerd
he was passing everybody pamphlets right
I walked by he didn't give me one
you probably want you to eat all the
free food out there they don't have free
food bro fine I sit there and I walk by
and I kind of noticed I was like wait
hold on a second [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is
my pamphlet you know why why all the
only Asian one walking by he give me one
your pythons doesn't work on you
probably knows you're too smart
it's not like that I was a little bit
magic I kind of want to come up look
scary as [ __ ] like what's wrong with me
bro it's like these are these psychics
in LA man like first of all how there's
so many psychic places I'm going to
they say open they obviously have to be
cocaine and hand jobs right that's what
they gotta be selling cooking I love the
Ford rent these prices they only need a
handful of people to stick with them and
they couldn't get a lot of money out of
them go with your girlfriend they'll
kick the guy out and they just keep the
girl in there cuz they know they can
like emotionally manipulate them but AG
I'll be like that's you're talking out
of your ass you're saying a hundred
percent of all their clients are women
it's gotta be 98 percent and 2 percent
gay guys yeah all girls for sure man
yeah well we were walking by and my and
the lady's like you want the psychic
reading my girl is like yeah she's like
but he has to go cuz you're gonna be
picking it apart like logically like
pulling her [ __ ] yeah we got a
psychic reading me and my friend Tim and
this lady it was so hard not to laugh
cuz it was just the most Vegas [ __ ]
you ever heard cuz she would ask me
stuff that I want and then she would
just do a psychic reading about the
stuff that I just told you that I wanted
you know every trick a nobody and she
goes I could see that you're a kind
person that wants to be successful yeah
every body [ __ ] very very good about I
just keep staring at the plaque in her
teeth I was like oh I'm so nasty they
use a lot of tactics because people want
to hear things people don't know how
much they want to hear [ __ ] that's
confirmed it's called a confirmation
bias right like the things that they
want the world to exist like in their
head that's true more likely to take
this stuff in so these manipulators are
really good at that [ __ ] so these
psychics that can channel like a family
member or whatever they'll start fishing
like man you had a loss and they're like
yeah yeah how'd you know I had a loss
yeah it was a your family they're like
yeah yeah how did you know it was my
sister too like yeah I knew it was just
a dumb ass person they give so much
information they don't know I'd be like
oh really what else happened who's that
dude on public television that used to
do is pop off right knows it pop I know
that Williams had a medium guy yeah the
medium you he was just a crowd of people
right he goes yeah you you have family
yeah yeah your person you breed you have
teeth people are like wow
yeah they used to film that for two
hours but edit it down to a 20-minute
video because they're just fishing
fishing for [ __ ] non-stop I guess like
some of the most it would be it would be
so ridiculous it'll be like this like
you have a sister they're like no a
brother yeah a sibling economy finally
one of them you know and they get their
mind blown from that you ever seen those
hypnotist you ever go to a live
hypnotist show not everybody can be
hypnotized the more gullible you are the
more easy so they bring a bunch of
people on there like okay sleep some
people like there but the people still
up there like okay get offstage you're
ruining my [ __ ] you ruin my [ __ ] all the
gullible people that end up doing it
some people are more susceptible to this
[ __ ] they know how to rely on who is
more willing to act like a chicken yeah
so they know like when they work the
audience they'll be like yeah they're
like oh here's a goofy [ __ ] like
he probably likes attention come up so
hypnotizing is really just bringing out
people's personality it's really
interesting it's not taking over their
mind or controlling them or doing any of
those things it's really understanding
people immediately and going like okay
this is how you see the world I know
what type of person you are you're more
likely to agree about this so you'll do
that it's pretty it's pretty nuts
oh yeah hypnotize but just do it fake
and just say some crazy [ __ ] like Tony
Robbins you ever watch that guy they
have that Netflix thing I'm like there's
no way he didn't plant everybody in
there yeah there's big Netflix and yell
allegedly but it's just like I've done
stand-up it's like it never goes that
smooth like that when you're doing crowd
work like that
everybody's just knocking it out of the
park and it's just it's all just like
crowd works snake oil salesman [ __ ]
people just want to be told it's all
gonna work out sometimes I don't mind
being blind if it does me positive
that'll go to these seminars and [ __ ]
I'll be like [ __ ] yeah energy and then
like I know everyone else is like
motivated so I just want to jump in the
Train but I know in the back of my head
that's just fake as [ __ ] but then here's
my thing if a placebo works it still
[ __ ] works so I don't give a damn
they say you can control your fate you
know I mean you can yeah
be President someday BEC that might be
really hard but you can control you know
the energy in your life yeah attraction
yeah yeah and then like people who like
drama you know they're always in drama
because they love just true they love it
they love like to get outraged all the
time you see the same people on the
internet always complaining about
everything cuz they they want that that
they attract that energy yeah man well
that's probably why people that are
highly successful or super egotistical
and super delusional because you have to
be you have to think like I'm gonna
[ __ ] rule the goddamn world and
nothing's gonna stop me and not listen
to any opposition for you to get that
time well look at kick boxers MMA guys
well either interviews I'm the king I'm
the best nobody could stop me I'm bad
news and they're never the same because
had their word illusion that that thing
that just kept them going I want to be
bat delusional I think I'm gonna be that
guy gets my ass kicked 20 times I'm on
the [ __ ] best didn't know there was a
guy that's like three and like 200 he
would just be called in fights and one
time he tapped because he didn't like
how is his cup was sitting on his so he
tapped what that's [ __ ] hilarious
dude yeah
[Music]